speaking of people who were clearly
poorly educated
don lemon don lemon on cnn
uh theologian cardinal
future pope don lemon was
discussing religion recently right he
was discussing the vatican's
decision to continue to hold the
christian view of marriage that they've
held for 2000 years
so don lemon was spouting off he said
look god would never judge anybody
never mind that in the nicene creed we
acknowledge that
uh christ will come to judge the living
and the dead and his kingdom will have
no end no forget about that forget all
the references to judgment in the bible
no no judgment no vatican they've got to
get on board with
the don lemonite christianity don lemon
is now making
both a theological and historical claim
that jesus is black and we also have to
start
being realistic about god and the bible
and if you
are a person of faith in this country
and you we know america is built on
faith and religious freedom
then we have to i think a good way of
starting
is to present the true identity of jesus
and that is as a black or a brown person
rather than someone who looks like a
white hippie from
uh sweden or norway and i think we
should start with a true depiction of
what jesus looked like and put that in
your home
either a black jesus or brown jesus
because we knew jesus looked more like a
muslim or someone who was dark
rather than someone who was blonde uh a
blonde looking carpenter
and then when your children ask you who
is this this is jesus
jesus was middle eastern bethlehem was
not in
in sweden and so jesus does not look
like
the um popular depiction that we have
in our churches uh and in our homes and
that we see all over the media
and i think that is a good place to
start
jesus is not a black guy first of all
when you begin with
jesus was as as you're pontificating to
christians about their religion you've
made a crucial error
because christ was crucified and then he
rose again from the dead and ascended
into heaven and is seated at the right
hand of god the father almighty
jesus is a jew his mother
was mary his father is god
the father the first person of the
blessed trinity in christ is the second
person of the blessed trinity
and the holy spirit the bond of love
between the father and the son is the
third person of the blessed trinity so
real is that love that it
he is his own person
just for don lemon to come and say look
we just have to deal with the historical
facts okay jesus was black
that's historically ridiculous it's just
not true
well jesus wasn't swedish yet no one
says he was swedish
do you have you looked at any uh western
art any western depictions of christ
they vary some i guess he's lighter
skinned than others but
he looks like a jew
i don't know he doesn't look black you
don't look swedish he doesn't look
norwegian or whatever he
looks like a jewish guy which is what he
is
there are also some clues as to what
christ looked like in his bodily form uh
in as he was incarnate on earth and
we can see this in the shroud of turin
we can see this in other places
but the the historical claim is
silly and we can dismiss it the worst
part of it is
that he's ignoring the central
fact of christ the the most important
fact
he knows uh just about as much about
depictions of jesus as he does about
higher christology
the error here is trying to center
christ's identity in race
there is neither jew nor greek nor slave
nor free but all are one in christ jesus
christ who comes as a jew to this
specific chosen people
has his message spread by the apostles
to all of the gentiles to all of the
world
all coming into one in human human
dignity human solidarity
salvation open to all mankind and this
schmuck don lemon focuses on
kooky theories about the race of the
redeemer of the world who could possibly
care less
about the race of the redeemer of the
world the fact is the redemption
don lemon missing the point i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you